all right that took away my desire to
hit the jewel on air since they won't be
coming to arrest me darn there's such a
good opportunity i know the liberal
media mob is probably devastating anyway
here with reaction on a more serious
note florida attorney general pam bondi
along with the co-host of the buck and
clay
show buck sexton is with us um pam i
look at this and i'm like okay
we have all these opioid deaths
overdoses they have open borders they're
not doing a thing there uh we have we
don't even do background checks on
people that are processing and releasing
into the country and they get a free
phone they don't get a cover check and
they don't get a vaccine mandate so they
get preferential treatment why are they
going after this one company
you know sean and we can't talk about
this enough and i'm so glad we're
talking about it tonight because the
unintended consequence of this is as you
said it's not illegal to possess or use
so you're safe tonight but when they
take it off the market what teens are
going to do they're going to go to the
black market and when they do it's going
to be laced with fentanyl just like
we've seen i've seen it my entire career
when things like this happen that is an
unintended consequence so parents you
need to talk to your kids because if
they can't buy it legally and adults if
you can't buy it legally be careful if
you're buying it on the street it will
be laced most likely with something else
and you can be hurt and yes they're
putting out crack pipes they're giving
out needles for heroin addicts taxpayer
dollars are paying for those
so you know the hypocrisy um well how do
they justify making 12 billion how do
they justify making 12 billion on
cigarettes every year buck i'll throw
that to you
yeah
and there's clearly no principle
involved here for them but again sean
when you look at just the recent history
of the fda and how they were asleep at
the wheel on the baby formula issue
which has now caused a baby formula
shortage that is still ongoing all
across the country the fda joins the cdc
and the fbi and some other three-letter
agencies as places that just can't seem
to get the job done and continue to
engage in either politicization or
distraction like this uh there is no
principle they can point to for why this
would be banned but cigarettes would
continue and then when you add this also
just to the mentality uh that you've
seen from the white house of saying that
there should be
chemical
gender transition drugs or puberty
blocking drugs for children and yet here
the fda is stepping in to say but we're
doing this to protect the children i
feel like they don't really know what
that what that means or it doesn't mean
what they think it does
yeah and the same group of people pam
that without any science behind it they
want to give vaccines to kids under five
uh and fauci even admits they didn't
have any studies that show the
effectiveness of it or maybe
the negative impact of it
i'm just trying to understand the logic
why this one company because other
vaping companies have are not
at all impacted by this why'd they
single out this one company that already
had pulled out their flavored
uh brands that they had like mango and
passion fruit whatever you call them
that younger kids seem to like and they
kept the more traditional cigarette
flavors which is like tobacco and
menthol and that's it why would they
pick on one company and meanwhile these
other companies are selling the flavored
vape
i guess pods whatever you call
them well sean it's it it sounds like
the company jewel will appeal and it
sounds like they probably will be
successful because they don't have it
says the fda they don't have the data to
back up a complete ban on this one
company so they probably will be
successful but again in the meantime i
think people are going to go to the
black market to buy products um
this is really scary you really think
what they're going to do is when people
go to the black market you suspect that
people that buy they're not looking for
weed they're just looking for nicotine
and you suspect that they're going to
lace these with fentanyl you think
that's going to be
i do sean i saw it when i was attorney
general with people adults buying
adderall xanax on the street it was
being laced with fentanyl and people
were dropping dead they still are that's
why you should never buy anything on the
street even if it's an adderall or a
xanax in nothing because of that problem
and now it will be happening with these
electric cartridges because you can't
buy them legally so people need to be
very careful and then they sell
cigarettes can you explain that part to
me you know the ones with the chemicals
and the additives uh that we're told
caused the cancer
and the secondhand smoke that everyone
gets when you're you know when you're
around cigarettes as well
yeah and people addicted to nicotine
they say it's more addictive buck than
it than even heroin
yeah of course i mean maybe they have
they have better uh lobbyists or some of
the folks who are sending checks from
the other companies know which palms to
grease i mean sean it just doesn't make
sense but again when you're looking at a
federal bureaucracy and a binding
apparatus that is in such disarray uh
you have to expect that there be this
kind of cognitive dissonance operating
at all levels all the time because who's
really steering this ship i mean i'd
like to see them fix the baby formula
crisis and figure out if it's going to
be you know eight boosters or five
boosters or however many they want the
five-year-olds to get before the fda
starts arbitrarily pulling products off
the market and telling us that they're
doing it to protect the kids from what
could be seeping out of the product
they're not sure yet they'll get back to
us at some point in the future sounds
like the federal government doesn't know
what it's doing these days sean not a
surprise last question legal question
pam so if it's not illegal to possess it
and it's not illegal to use it which
means they won't arrest me
what if you go can you buy it from
another country is that going to be
legal
they can't stop you from buying it from
another country and importing it i'm
sure
but yes they cannot stop you from using
it they cannot stop you from possessing
it because fda they don't have that
power
nor is doj going to ever try to create
something where they could enforce
something in that manner so yes you can
buy it somewhere else but my fear again
don't buy it on the street
i think well said all right pam thank
you buck good to see you thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else